hello everyone this is amir from audio
science review
today uh we're back to uh reviewing uh
products but also
as with uh previous reviews it'll be a
sort of a tutorial on how to read the
graphs and
and the underlying architecture in these
devices
but a couple years ago a company
from china called hadas or kadas or
catas however you pronounce it
k-h-a-d-a-s
uh brought a revolutionary product it
was a board
um that sort of looked like this and for
99 dollars
it it had incredible performance
that became quite famous as a result of
our review and
many people bought these and used them
in their own devices so you could take
them and build your own streamer
get a raspberry pi plug it in and you
have yourself a very high performance
product fast forward two years later a
lot of companies have come up with
finished products that finish tax for 99
that
have incredible performance so the
company uh
has come up with a second generation
tone 2 product
and they've also built one with a case
because
case was a major issue with the first
one people try to make their own
and you know with just aggravation so
they now have
two versions of this one in the bare
board format which i just showed you
and also one in this uh sort of unusual
looking case
feels very nice in person when i saw
pictures of it i thought it looked kind
of hokey
it has a interesting innovation in that
these rca connectors look like
standard rca connectors except that they
actually have a
third ring inside of so you can actually
use a special cable
say cell which converts uh which gives
you balanced output differential output
so out of the same space that an rca
connector would take
you now can use a regular rca so it's
backwards compatible
or use this special cable
excuse me for reaching down on the floor
um and that's what it looks like i don't
know if
you can see the camera you probably
can't uh but anyway
inside this rca looking thing there is
also the uh
another ring here and when you plug this
into here
on the other side now you have a
three-pin standard uh
balance connection so as you can imagine
this is way too big to have on a device
this small
you can get mini xlrs and other things
but then if you had
mini xlrs in here then you need to have
another one for rca and
essentially you couldn't build something
uh this compact
so uh pretty cool device uh
back uh i suppose made to be a portable
form factor
kind of hard for me to imagine what the
scenario is for this in that
uh it you know all the cables will tug
on it and so you really need to have
portability in mind and
smallness in mind to care about this um
different from the original one is that
we also have um
balanced and unbalanced uh
headphone jacks and which i'll also
cover in the review
and this is a rotary control and
unfortunately brings us to the worst
aspect of this device in that
it has a bunch of options that you can
select from
filter to the gain setting for the
headphone
but to activate them you have to grab
this button and either push it once
forward or twice forward
and then there's a ring of lights that
come on
maybe i can plug it in and well maybe i
won't do it
mess up the video anyway a ring of
lights come on underneath
and how that that the colors are
identifies you know what mode you're in
you sort of turn this
and the different light stands and
there's a video on it and without it
though
you'll be totally lost i tried i
couldn't make it do anything even with a
video tutorial
it is atrocious it's extremely hard to
navigate through so
i struggled through it and uh produced
the results that i wanted but
uh you know if you're gonna set it once
and and
be done maybe it's all right but i think
this is a miss
despite the great effort that they put
in it
so uh with that out of the way uh why
don't we uh
look at the uh product itself as far as
the review and measurements
this details of the board if you care to
look inside and see what it's using a
classic uh xmos usb interface and what
have you
uh this is the usbc port on the right
and there's a i scored s in the form of
usbc which i haven't seen
and uh but you can also use this just to
have a cleaner power if you need it i
don't think that's
you need that and as you'll see from my
testing
um so uh we usually have our standard
dashboard
and i started with a balanced output
very nice to see 4 volts output
out of dac and synad which is a ratio of
noise
plus distortion compared to our signal
our signal is this in the middle
and you can see that it's
extremely good 118 state of the art is
about
121 these days is it or 120.
and you can see where it finishes in
balance mode it's
uh almost you know it's i think number
14 or 15 from the top but it's only like
a couple dbs that separates these guys
from each other
um i was a little surprised that when i
tested out
just the rca output without the special
adapter performance dropped more than i
expected it went down to 113 and 111
you can see the reason for it is this
cluster of noise
out here in higher frequencies um
looks to be some kind of uh you know
noise on the ground plane of usb
or something that's bleeding through and
but shows you the
reason to use balanced output uh it
really
rids you from a lot of uh dependency on
how clean the upstream ground is
uh in your audio product and audio
system that you're building so
if you can get the balanced output
for this you can see the effect of the
uh
rca out as far as how much lower the
dynamic ranges we're
down to 113 and 115 versus almost 120
when we use balanced output on the right
so
you know it's a dollar bill probably not
but uh
might as well get the performance that
you paid for it although
you have to buy that adapter cable and i
don't know how much it cost
um so for the rest of these tests i stay
with balance whenever i have a balanced
product
i assume you bought it because you want
to use balance otherwise
the usually cheaper options one test we
run
is this intermodulation test which is a
60 hertz
and a seven killers two tones not one
tone the previous test was one tone
this one has two tones the four to one
ratio and amplitude
the low frequency one is four times
louder than the high frequency one
and then we look for intermodulation uh
patterns between these two if the
system's perfect you put two tones in
you get two tones out
but the system has any non-linearities
you put two tones in and you get a lot
more tones out
and there's also noise this declining
portion of the graph
always tells you that basically noise is
dominating
because as the signal gets stronger the
fixed level of noise becomes a smaller
and smaller
portion of the overall signal and
therefore performance improve
so here we see that when we start at
minus 60 db
we coincidentally also have minus 60 db
of
of signal noise ratio or uh
noise and distortion ratio but as we go
higher and higher
performance improves now typically dacs
start to then
tilt back up at this point when they
flatten
noise and distortions have become equal
and then distortion starts to get louder
and louder and it dominates when the
graph
tilts up here we almost don't see that
so it's all
basically noise the distortion is
essentially negligible in this product
and
beats my standard reference which is
this topping dx
3 pro so extremely good performance
state-of-the-art dax a little bit less
noisy and that's how they get that extra
2 db of
performance another test i run is called
linearity
i feed the 200 hertz digital signal
and then what comes out of a dac we
heavily filter so all we're looking at
is really
just that 200 hertz and we look to see
if that level
is what we predict so if i feed a
digital minus 120 db
i expect to see an analog signal that's
120 db
lower than than the reference which in
this case is four volts
uh this used to be a tough test many dax
would flunk this
and ever since i started running it more
and more companies are
paying attention to this and now we're
seeing just
exceptional performance even in budget
products so
here you see that even at minus 120 db
which is this point down here
there's basically no air zero db error
so
this is a big big number this is 20 bits
down we've taken a 4 volt value divided
by 2 to the power of 20
and still managed to get zero deviation
so this device probably more
accurate to even below this level so
quite a nice accomplishment
people complain and say that well your
tests are one tone well so far i've
showed you two tones so it's not all one
tone but we also run tests called the
multi-tone there's actually 32
tones mixed together in a special way
with the special phase which i won't get
into why but
a perfect system would produce these 32
tones with nothing else
we don't have a perfect system we have
some noise and we have intermodulation
distortion
same problem i talked about before here
this performance is just exceptional
we see that at low frequencies our
distortions down to -130
and uh at higher frequencies usually
distortion noise increases and we have a
little bit of that maybe
but really it's about 22 bits of
distortion free range
a system that does 20 bits is already
fantastic and to get 22 bits
it's just amazing um other
state-of-the-art product
state-of-the-art products also do that
but again we're talking about a package
you know
system that's a couple hundred dollars
for the headphone amp and everything
built in
so job well done clearly engineers were
paying attention
a test we runs called the jitter test
it's really not a jitter test in that
um we anything that's sparious and
unwanted shows up in this test
so we run a signal called j test which
for now assume it just means a 12 kilos
tone
and then we expect to just see that and
nothing else
here we see this symmetrical view of all
these pulses
and when they're symmetrical most of the
time it means it's actually
jitter because if you take a signal and
you modulate left and right
you get two side bands one below it one
above it and still was symmetrical if
they're not symmetrical
like this one here that means that's
just some source of noise
inside the device um there's two clock
modes in this thing
but haven't helped me if i could figure
out how to get into the clock mode
to change it it's supposed to have a
clock mode that gets rid of jitter
but i it was just so deep in inside this
set of menus they're hard to navigate
that i did not get a chance to muck with
it maybe
the other mode makes it better i don't
even know which one is the default right
now
but uh fortunately that these are minus
130 db
so definitely not an audible problem
the dax silicon that these companies use
um
in this case an ess stack they always
have a set of filters
when you the principle of sampling
theorem says that if you want to have a
transparent channel
when you encode something you have to
bail limited to half the sampling rate
at encoding time at analog to digital
conversion
and then when you convert the digital
samples back to analog you again have to
apply the exact same filter that filter
ideally
has 100 response up to the half the
sample rate and then
zero after that we can't build such
filters in
real life but we can approximate them
and
there are different algorithms people
come up with different ideas of how you
do this filtering
some filters for example have ringings
in the
when you get close to the top some are
slower some of them have time domain
issues some of them don't audibility of
them is quite suspect
know that so don't go crazy over it but
one thing we do want to have is that
after the attenuation happens
we want it to be essentially no signal
so we want
very deep in attenuation 100 db or
better
for some reason this dac only attenuates
down to 60 db
i don't understand i change the modes
and some of them you can see they
attenuate a lot and then they go back to
not attenuating i don't know if it's a
hardware problem software problem
or maybe testing by me but this is the
standard test i run every deck i
i don't know i haven't seen this before
so
i'll be curious to know why it's doing
this because i know the dac itself is
not noisy
but why the out-of-band area is is
you know it's got very high level of
noise relatively speaking 50 db
so you know that's hopefully a company
will respond
and let us know what's going on there
the uh
that when you have this i can always
predict what
the performance gonna be terrible in the
next test
this is a frequency sweep where we
digitally create different tones at
different frequencies
and we sweep from 20 hertz to 20 000
hertz the audible band
now what we're looking for is harmonic
distortion what is a harmonic is
multiples of the pro
of the signal that we're interested in
so system that's perfect if i feed it
one kilohertz i get back one killers
but if it's not perfect you may generate
even harmonics so it may be one killer
is two kilos four kilohertz or maybe odd
one three five or maybe a mix of both
um to capture the harmonics of 20
kilohertz the second harmonic got
20 kilos at 40 kilos third harmonics at
60 kilos so we need to
when i'm running my analyzer i need to
open this input bandwidth
even though the sample rate here is only
48 kilohertz
i have to capture more than that to be
able to catch the harmonic distortions
of
of these frequencies now i could make it
infinite
but then it picks up a whole bunch of
other things we're not interested in
so as a compromise i set the bandwidth
to 90 kilohertz
once it said that 90 kilohertz then i
can even catch the fourth
uh harmonic of 20 kilohertz and after
that harmonic distortion
usually drops off so what this test does
though then
it not only gathers the distortion but
the
measurements actually noise and
distortion thd
plus n n stands for noise when the dac
doesn't filter out the outer band as we
call it the ultrasonic
frequencies that stuff all shows up in
this measurement
as if they're distortion but in reality
their images of the signal
reflect reflected back and they get
summed in this
test and in this case because the
attenuation was very poor
you can see this graph in here in red
the original
stone board look at how clean that was
compared to this
that does not mean that this device has
a lot more distortion
it just means that it's filtering is not
great and
in this measurement it just looks awful
we can prove that by changing the sample
rate to 192 kilohertz
when we do that 90 kilohertz is actually
in-band
we don't need this filter basically the
filter is not needed
for that measurement and you can see
what happens to its performance now it
becomes incredibly good
easily beating its last generation board
the
brown and green is the 192 kilohertz
version so we've proven that
this is not any kind of inherent
distortion because if we just change the
sample rate
performance improves tremendously
fortunately this is
not an audible thing because harmonic
distortion
and you know and stuff above
20 killers are not audible anyway
but you know from engineering point of
view we measure things we look for
excellence
and in this one area it's just uh
something's wrong with this filter and
again
hopefully it's a firmer programming
issue with the
core silicon that same chip is used in
many other products and don't do this
we know the dac itself is extremely
quiet so
we'll have to see what they respond
so that's the dac portion of it that's
using the
line outs uh on this thing by the way
the third connector on this is spdif
coax
there's no optical but you have a coax
input also
um so switching the headphone the
original product didn't have a headphone
output it had the option for one but
they never brought it out
so there's two gain settings in there
here
low gain and high gain and it ships with
low gain as the default
and the low gain mode has incredibly low
noise and distortion but
very little power and i almost
chucked it because i said wow it's got
no power
then i realized that the uh it has a you
know high gain setting and i went ahead
and did one more test
because it has both bounce and on
balance i have to
run the test multiple times so if you
look in here this
red curve at the bottom here
is the maximum power we can get versus
distortion and noise
and it's only five milliwatts five
millivolts is what you get out of a
phone dongle
so it's not a lot of power in low game
mode but if you have a very
sensitive iem that may be all you need
and if it is you're getting incredibly
low noise and distortion
better than my reference desktop product
that's in dashed blue
if you use unbounce it's this gray line
and it doesn't even put out one
milliwatt and it gets distorted from
0.1 milliwatts so not a lot of
distortion but
so i really don't see unbalanced
being usable um with this
with a high impedance headphones sorry i
forgot to mention this is a 300 ohm
load so but if you go to balance mode
and high gain you get this blue graph
and now you get 52 milliwatt
for a desktop product my standard is 100
milliwatt
if you get 100 milliwatt you have you
can drive
almost 99 of the headphones that are out
there
52 milliwatts is still pretty good um
again a typical dongle for your phone is
five
so it's a lot more powerful than what
you would get out of a phone
um the first test that we just ran
excuse me is a test of how much voltage
we have because the impedance high
there are headphones with impedance very
low and when impedance very low we don't
care as much about voltage we care about
current
that's what delivers power so running
the same test now
we see that the low gain mode in red
balance is still quite good
unbalance is still uh it puts out a
little bit more power 10 milliwatts but
it's just pathetic you need more than
that um
going to balance mode in blue had this
distortion hump
which was kind of unusual some kind of
distortion sets in and then
it disappears i don't know what that is
and usually don't see a hump like that
but there's some kind of distortion
mechanism that kicks in
luckily even at this level still minus
85 db so i don't think you'll
hear this one but eventually it hits a
brick wall
and runs out of current and he clips and
he goes this hockey stick of
just shooting way up so you obviously
don't
don't want to you know get past that
whenever a device like this has a
headphone amplifier i always listen
because listening will tell me whether
this limit is actually something i can
hit or not
and i use two test headphones always
same two first one is a mass drop ether
cx
by dan clark audio and
the reason it uses only has it has an
impedance of only 25 ohms
so it's a low impedance and relatively
inefficient
it brings many headphone amplifiers to
their knees and
here in balanced mode
using this this box it managed to get
pretty loud i mean it was comfortably
allowed for desktop use
and so definitely very usable
but i could crank it up beyond that
point and it would get
very distorted very audibly distorted
and i wasn't going deaf
it was very loud but so know that there
is a limit and indeed this clipping
point you will hit
um we have 200 milliwatts in here
high-powered desktop amps will go
one two three watts or even more so
we're about 10x lower than what we get
in a powerful desktop
amp but remember this is the usb powered
so it's all the juice you can pull out
of the
usb socket and doesn't have an external
power supply which the
high power desktop amps have but you can
definitely
if you have a headphone like this you
can take it on the road with you with
this little device and
still be all set i then switched hd 650
sennheiser
that i use as a high impedance headphone
um
i have balance cables for it but i
always use it in unbalanced mode
and i plugged it in here it produced
music background level volume
it lacked impact like dynamic range and
it certainly didn't get very loud
didn't get distorted either but you
definitely need a balanced
uh cable for it uh at least if you're me
you know if you listen to very low
levels of
uh of sound and maybe don't and in that
case i don't even know if you need this
just use your phone or something
so where are we on this thing uh it's a
little difficult to rate this
uh product because if that filter was
perfect uh i'll tell you i would give it
the
one of the highest rewards i could it'd
be state of the art
and usually i don't care about that
filter but
it's just that the attenuation is not
there and then secondarily the user
interface i usually don't rate this
user interface in my reviews i my uh
verdict is based on performance design
i'll let you be the judge of the
functionality on your own
but in this case i just thought it
it was so bad that i had to incorporate
it so because of those two reasons
um i still recommend it i still think
this is a
nice option to look at especially for
size form factor
balance on balance headphones and
everything including this little device
so you should consider it but i can't
give it my highest rating that i would
if they fix that filter issue then
i will i will highly recommend it and i
might even go back and and
change my rating to it but uh for now
good product i appreciate them sending
it to me um
i couldn't find pricing on this board by
the way this is 200
from them i couldn't find pricing on
this
i don't know the original one was 99
dollars i assume
this is i maybe this is just an oem
product or maybe i just couldn't find it
but uh if you use this just as a dac
maybe you don't have to deal with all
the
grief of the user interface and if it's
half the price again you can build
incredible streamers with this i mean
you combine this with a
raspberry pi or something and uh you
know you're in heaven or you can stick
it in the little
uh intel pc or whatever however you
build your streamer and have this in
there and
it'll have better performance than multi
thousand dollar boutique products
okay thanks for stopping by and uh
hopefully
if even if you weren't interested in
this product you learned something about
the
measurements and how to read and
interpret them okay
see you in a future video bye-bye